I'm trying to stay healthy today I um I
got a nice walk-in nice long walk in
yeah I made it to the kitchen and back
boom smash that's that's that passes for
a joke when you're in quarantine trust
me
was there an audience here huge laughs
massive laughs what stuff about what
else is going on
see what's in the news checking out
right here oh here it is yeah not sure
you heard this but Disney is expected to
ask visitors to wear masks when they
visit their parts yeah yeah they're also
asking visitors maybe for now stay away
from sneezy
he's a super spreader yeah he'll you'll
get killed thousands oh here's a story
they say that if all the industry's porn
is the one that's gonna make the
quickest comeback yeah of course now
porn is gonna consist mostly of two
people hugging each other that's right
baby
oh yeah yeah yeah touch my face that's
it baby
this porn in this environment yeah well
those are very funny jokes you don't
even have to worry about it I've just
declared them funny I'm a professional
so nothing for you to worry about